there may be some aspiring writers
in this group who
want to do novels or short stories of
your own
one of the things that you will probably
hear
from a lot of uh teachers and people who
give advice to aspiring writers is uh
write what you know
at least in in the united states in
english literature this is something
always said to aspiring writers write
what you know
when i was a young writer i hated
hearing that
because i didn't know anything really
i i was this kid from the projects in
bayonne new jersey i had never gone
anywhere never had any money
i i wanted to write fantasy and science
fiction but i'd certainly never seen a
dragon i'd never gone to another planet
i'd never done any of this stuff so how
could i write what i know
so i sort of rejected that and said well
that's that's [ __ ] i'm not going to
follow that advice
but later it it and when i actually
became a writer i
began to understand the truth of that
it's not
writing what you know in terms of the
care and raising of dragons
or it's it's writing the emotional truth
of your own life
and whatever whatever furniture you may
put into
your story whether it's a realistic
story about you know what it's like to
live in
barcelona in the year 2012 and
you know the day-to-day struggles of
life or whether you're
casting it in in a historical context
what it was like to live in spain in
1492
or whatever when the moors were
being kicked out and the jews were being
kicked out and columbus was discovering
america or
whether it's a far distant planet or
a fantasy world the core of it is still
what you know in terms of emotional
truth that's what's going to make the
characters come alive
that's what's going to make it real
now i have a friend a contemporary
who uh served in the united states armed
forces during the vietnam war
and he had
he had uh some very traumatic
experiences
over there he he saw some horrible
things
he he did some things he uh
learned a lot about war and the nature
of
humanity and um
it's clear that uh this this these
events that happened to him
between you know roughly the ages i
guess of
18 and 22 or 23
became in some ways the defining
characteristic of his life
and he has subsequently written a number
of books and
some of them are realistic books
novels about the vietnam war novels
about
coming home after the vietnam war some
of them are science fiction books
about other wars in a thousand years
from now
fought among the stars but you can read
those other war
those those science fiction books and
you can see
that the power in them derives from the
fact that he served in the vietnam war
and he knows what he was talking about
there's that core
of emotional truth there he's writing
what he knows
he's writing from the heart or from the
gut
as you might say
and that's what makes his work his best
work so powerful when he
doesn't write about war i think he
produces some very entertaining books
but they don't necessarily have the same
power as when he's writing about
the subject that he really knows
um which brings me back to me
who did not serve in the vietnam war who
in fact was part of the anti-war
movement
resisting it i was at home
um i went to college and then i got out
of college
and the big defining characteristics of
my life
in in these periods was i had a number
of women who broke my heart
and it seems very trivial compared to
serving in the vietnam war but boy it
didn't feel trivial to me
and uh um i
the questions of love and romance and
sexuality
and existential loneliness um
occupied my mind and obsessed me
for years and as a result i produced
a series of intensely romantic science
fiction
short stories and novels about guys who
are getting their hearts broken among
the stars
including dying and light which i think
is the ultimate
the ultimate example of it so i too was
writing what you know
even though i've never been to the
planet warlorn or
seen a society like that of high cavalen
or any of the things that were in there
those were the imaginative constructs
but the emotional heart of the book goes
back to
write what you know